how is everybody doing today does anyone
have a question they want to ask we've
never done this i've never asked anybody
if they i wanted to have a question and
not because i think oh i'm sure
someone's dying to ask me a question is
not coming from an indulgent place i was
just curious does anyone have a question
we've never done this before this will
be at first yes yellow hi you're just
wondering nice and light good morning
what's your favorite snack oh
my favorite snack
you know i'll tell you something
exciting what's your name by the way
elisa i'm true
oh from scotland
by the way
i gotta check up on something i might be
going to scotland this summer
well
by the way can you imagine i like show
up at your doorstep and take you up on
it all right give me your phone number
i'll stalk you later
what instagram
yeah i do seriously i now have a friend
in scotland if i end up going there i
did i saw zendaya
who's like
personally one of my most favorite
people to freak out over
and we were at this fashion thing and i
kept saying to her we were like kind of
being ushered like little cows um to the
thing and we were all squeezing in like
a tight hallway and i was like i love
you i love you and i just kept saying i
love you to her and then my brain was
like come up with something original you
said i love her 500 times so i was like
out of curiosity what's your favorite
snack right now
and i asked zendaya that question and do
you want to know her answer
she looked at me like oh i haven't
gotten asked that in a while so i was
like yes i gave zendaya a fresh question
and she was like
garlic knots
and i was like i love you i love you i
love you i love you and i went just back
to the i love yous so it is fun to be
asked your favorite snack um
i don't i don't i mean i don't nachos
i'm so into not i love nachos i want
nachos all the time
um you definitely get cravings whether
you're pregnant or not
um and mine are not you're pregnant
hi mama
and you're wearing the good vibes what's
your name ken k-i-n got it um
congratulations
what's your craving right now
pickles and olives
i like it salty
ugh i when i was pregnant i would
wake up and eat a cheeseburger then move
on to ramen and then have tacos and then
i was like and it's definitely time for
a grilled cheese and a hot dog
followed up with like a tub of ice cream
you know what's so fun when you're
pregnant your stomach is really tight
and i've never had a tight stomach i've
always had like the stomach of a sharpie
dog like there's lots of rolls to pull
and when i was pregnant i was like look
at how tight this
and it felt so good